first it's time to have some fun with
our good friend las vegas now host
mercedes martinez
live this morning at the mix 9401
studios mercedes good morning to you
what's trending today
hey john it's officially the holidays
because
mariah carey's all i want for christmas
is you
is the number one song on the global 200
chart
it has been 26 years since the las vegas
headliner released
that song now keeping with the holiday
theme here this
morning it was an elf reunion 17 years
in the making
buddy the elf and jovi spread some
christmas cheer by singing
loud for all to hear that's enough
reference if you don't know
they reunited virtually over the weekend
and they reenacted
the iconic scene where buddy is in the
bathroom while she's saying baby
it's cold outside i love that scene
i think we can reenact that maybe you
and alex later on today have you seen
that movie
so it's funny to mention that actually
some of us from the station we all
we rented a theater over at the orleans
and we all sat in the feeder all spread
out and watched elf and i had never seen
it before so we got to watch it and
have the popcorn on the whole deal so
that was a little a little fun elf
experience
getting the holiday spirit that sounds
amazing i love that idea so we are going
to see a john and alex
duet here is what you're saying right i
mean i don't want to spill anything but
you know where it's a work in progress
maybe uh mercedes let's switch gears
let's talk about
uh las vegas headliner smokey robins in
the legend
he's gone viral uh
frank in a weird reason this is yeah
it's kind of funny
it's cute the motown legend recorded a
cameo video
for a fan and the guy wanted robinson to
wish his mom
a happy hanukkah however there were
several different ways to spell
hanukkah and apparently robinson hadn't
seen the way to spell it
with a ch so without further ado
here it is and they want me to wish you
happy chanukah
i have no idea what chanukah is
but happy chanukah because they said so
anyway god bless you babe and enjoy
chanukah
apparently saying it spelled differently
through smokey off
and you know we all know it's it's
pronounced hanukkah
so just keep that in mind next time you
see the spellings
his heart was in the right place his
heart was in the right place there's no
trail
there's no uh tracks of his tears after
saying that it was an honest mistake
a lot of people online are saying hey
you know what let's start
saying chanukah it's absolutely adorable
and like you said his heart was in the
right place he was trying to do
something nice
it's all good happy hanukkah also we
should say 6 46
mercedes thanks for joining us this
morning have a good rest of your day
we'll see on las vegas